[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est 6ème en fait il est à vous dire
que évidemment toute la semaine on vous
fait gagner des places vous le savez
pour le match psg real charles lève les
yeux au ciel un bulletin
table allons-y les accents les
imitations pas y aller il est là qu on
parle même d' explosion en l'occurrence
déjà garder votre gauche français qu'on
était sur ses news mais en fait on est
bien sur bfm joie par rapport à une dit
pas non plus et s'attache à toi mais
parce que vous ne dites pas mais jamais
l'apa l'allocation blessés par les
matins en l'occurrence madame un opéra
mais représentation elle est très rapide
et un peu populiste moi et c'est la
dysphasie essayer de démontrer l'inversé
pas à calmer vos chiffres mais calmez
vous madame ça va bien se passer
aujourd'hui une baisse de 30 ans on est
en train de perdre votre sang-froid un
anachronisme
vraiment à vous êtes en train de perdre
votre sang-froid c'était qu'on vous pose
des questions vous sentez offensé ça se
passe à l'assemblée nationale ce soit
sur les plateaux de télé ça se passe
partout faut que vous acceptez qu'on
vous pose des questions parce qu'il est
pas offenser gérald darmanin à part la
pauline de madère et lui pose simplement
des questions ils se sont offensés et
agréé quand j'aurai le droit de répondre
débats et se nommer je trouve que vous
avez un vrai problème pour lui point un
vrai bâtard un corniaud le corniaud
ça va bien se passer il y avait bien se
passer mais je vous demande pardon comme
ça c'est madame vous allez voir mais
c'est à 30% et à 30% de baisse sur les
bien moi j'en ai marre des discours
populistes toute la journée puis c'est
sont vos chiffres étant tirés du site du
ministère vous n'évoquez même pas la
baisse des biens la baisse des conneries
je vous ai immédiatement demandé ce trou
à propos des violences faites aux pneus
ce n'est pas que je réponde non sur sa
cigarette manière de répondre à une
réponse est presque une chance je
réponds comme vous me vexez pas voilà ça
c'est de la télé j'adore voilà là là là
voilà la cdac la 6e ça voilà ça c'était
bien qu'on voit là on vous me direz ce
que vous en pensez mais voilà ça c'est
un vrai moment ce matin j'étais
tranquillement en train de voile à 2 2
quoi de quoi
est ce que gérald darmanin aurait eu le
même comportement face à jean-jacques
bourdin et je suis persuadé que non je
suis persuadé dernier où je vous donne
ma parole que jamais en fait gérald
darmanin aurait dit calmez vous monsieur
ça va bien se passer il est comme une
condescendance qui moi ma mamma m'a
vraiment frappé ce matin est ce que ça
vous a frappé aussi d'aller bien sûr
c'était assez assez assez gênant je te
rappelle que bourdon et puis là elle ne
remplace un peu plus c'était la guerre
entre bourg d'ariel bon alors out balala
eu besoin de marquer un peu sont très
bonnes fait pas des audiences absolument
incroyable ça va venir savons nous les
audiences c'est comme mon zizi savons
tout le temps il avait un comportement
d'homme face à une femme c'est un goujat
écoutez on verra si gérald darmanin
s'excuse en tout cas
ce clash mon petit monsieur ce qu'il est
petit en taille en sortir est grand le
message en cours pour la balade un coup
c'est combien alors pour conclure ce
reportage c'est quand même demander
l'avis d'un homme roval caméraman qu'on
ne voit jamais d'habitude il a choisi
surprise un slip très classique robin
mais inscrits en soyant licra est ce
qu'on peut demander un caméraman de
vachement décomplexée et détendue du
slip alors j'ai quand même la liste des
fantasmes les plus répandus en france et
des classiques le plan à trois les lieux
publics et les jeux de rôle 78% des
français préfèrent les câlins le soir
mais il reste 22 % qui sont plutôt du
matin et donc à 6h26 qui peut-être sont
en train de nous écouter on les salue
pour éviter d'avoir à repousser un rival
il a tout intérêt à se reproduire au
plus vite
[Musique]
alors ils redoublent d'efforts pour
l'impressionner
[Musique]
rien à faire elle semble totalement
indifférente à ses charmes j'ai
l'impression que je t'emmerde à l
impression moi j'ai envie de lui
répondre ouais ouais là tout de suite la
monarchie j'ai juste entendu dire à la
face il va faire un tour va détendre
l'aéro vient après
bon il commence à gonfler et je vais
perdre patience si ça continue vous
mieux avoir une fierté souffrir que ce
faire
que je faire ce faire sur nous ok ce
matin sur lci elizabeth martichoux
recevez nadine morano et je pense mais
je peux me tromper je pense qu'elle
avait hâte que l'interview se termine
puisqu'elle était prête à partir avant
même la fin voyez vous en tant qu en cas
de duel mais pour cela vous avez déjà
perdu donc positionné vous vous avez
déjà perdu moi je considère qu'on va
gagner donc je vais pas prétendre à sa
répondre c'est pas si est aussi une
question sur le vélo c'est
certainement ce que je te dis te fais
chier certainement oui mais tu veux pas
l'enfant à cette fesci l'espoir pourtant
tu remets pas en question n'est pas de
savoir d'accord ça c'est bien parce que
tu es d'accord avec moi tout le temps
c'est ouf vraiment tu t'en vas rien à
[__] qui trouve ma gueule et là je me
demande ce que je fous là nous étions
très honnêtement montant mois perd du
temps j'ai pas que ça à foot alors qu'un
nouveau combat débute le choix de la
femelle effet elle est finalement
séduite par cet outsider plus délicat
est plus discret
elles s'accouplent avec lui quand il me
prend dans ses bras qu'il me parle tout
bas
je vois la vie en
e
je ne pense rien y'a rien acheter gueule
dessus de quoi vous voulez qu'elle
conduit le dessus en fait je comprends
voilà ce que vous dites ces deux là et
là vous avez un match c'est tout n'est
pas foutu il me montre autre chose mais
si je suis foutu montre autre chose mais
là j'ai pas fait autre chose c'est toi
tu vas pas faire parce que j'étais
justement il avait rien dans le frigo
pour faire autre chose de mieux je sais
pas fait j'ai pas fait quelle est votre
impression générale moi je découvre le
monde du coût de la télévision donc
c'est un peu bizarre au début mais c'est
une bonne impression voilà quel faux
culs celui ci déjà il ya un constat plus
de la moitié des enfants ont augmenté
leur consommation d'écran depuis la
crise sanitaire voilà à quoi je pensais
pas que les enfants je pense que les
adultes également et il en ressort quand
on regarde en détail cette étude et ce
sont les parents qui le disent 43 % de
leurs enfants de 0 à 2 ans de rang les
bébés utilisent déjà internet
n'est pas bio et les fleurs
des flashs et papillons et des flops
peut-être j'aurai des papillons qu'ils
veulent qui vous venez
je crois que c'est l'heure de
l'entraînement charles à quoi c'est un
retrait
encore une fois juste envie de lui dire
mais chanter tu ne connais pas con
encore là + 1
moi je vous le dis franchement je sais
pas ce qui va sortir de la
voile sur ce elle a bien raison il avait
parti shas